okay we're going to play we're going to
play someone that's bad bad bring on the
placement by this classic classic can
with the play we ranked so people could
[ __ ] serious
that is when people get [ __ ] serious
okay
and kinda I really like to be someone
who people think to jet I'm part like we
gesture this game so it's going to
pretend them gesture oh [ __ ] I don't
think my name it's teddy bear fear daddy
bear is here
the cat mechanic ain't better yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah
transporter what the [ __ ] is transporter
what the [ __ ] is that your job is a
transfer people without asking any
questions what the [ __ ] is that man
I'm a daddy bear choose to fuel
transport I can't skin cancer
with baby bear okay
yeah like that baby
I am that I better prepare to be
transported [ __ ]
who is the one I shared an era
putting a time of purely because I
dislike dr. help
good thing we killed the Chester baby
bear I will always love and protect do
[ __ ] come on against that [ __ ]
perfect perfect okay
panties is Vance switched with gay I'm
transferring the panties okay I'm
transporting the pan to okay MA
I'm taking the panties from one location
and bringing them to the other location
[ __ ] by the panic sleeping in wait who's
the one that they [ __ ] tried to [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] it time I get murdered
whoo
it's only a doctor hope it can be our
friend right
all panting might sound side that
at the fat
why they going for baby bear
I love the Ripper baby but yeah
then [ __ ] Wow I [ __ ] left my
[ __ ] lip holy [ __ ] I'm in lo the
river baby yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
in love with a ripper baby yeah panties
Marva Sangha myself oh baby yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah baby yeah yeah
yeah
how do you [ __ ]
don't forget going for gay but baby
okay I'm gonna switch baby back which
can come sorry
mmm okay okay look soon happens every
let's say what happened oh wait no with
me because I bet I bet game is bad so
after I keep attacking try and try and
kill me so I'm switching myself I'm
alone with a ripper baby yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh transfer yourself what
someone is bye-bye Jane catchers that'll
shut
publicans repealing Obamacare
medium right let's [ __ ] is that give a
head check the Ripper
ever love with a weapon baby yeah yeah
yeah Oh baby
what [ __ ] them up I'm going to swap Jack
the Ripper
okay I've got I got bad
gotta go okay
baby yeah yeah yeah go and so that game
game
mm-hmm okay Gabe with half a story you
know penny
chant janitor man eater and jacquard we
switched does it already
okay it's go really [ __ ] well huh
that really [ __ ] them up I'm in love
with a ripper baby but yeah yeah yeah
hmm
no sound how does you know that [ __ ]
janitor janitor janitor Oh
shut
mmm
don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes I can count it [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well we [ __ ] it that good okay wait I
got okay marathons
okay memory okay let's say what havoc in
my date what is a curse what the [ __ ] is
that I don't have a little more right
the [ __ ] oh can I get a pet fur shape is
there a cheap pet hippity-hop err he's
cute
where's like the reject pets I want like
a boring pet bunny friend asset death
innovations holy [ __ ] and fun those five
dollars took that [ __ ] that I think
[ __ ] okay lobby icons that's look at
that do okay it's sucking day less can I
do right now
[ __ ] we need a [ __ ] I got to
somewhere let's see somewhere I practice
okay
and preparing yeah I love the chicken in
leggings baby yeah yeah yeah I need to
repaint the house and let's say let's
say hello right slack okay
there we go
hello I swag let's do this again we
Circle is that I'm the witch oh okay
[ __ ] yeah yeah hey parrot I got slagged
what's the trials as though
prepare to base select head base tonight
slave over at White House okay
the [ __ ] is his target okay [ __ ] Kill
Bill yeah
you
there you go
as a Democrat we need to get rid of
faith that right now there we go
hmm Wow
well well well adios Thomas - but cut
ourselves the low
Wow a plugin that means a little jaghana
hope they understand that I hope they
understand that
I think baby yeah yeah yeah now lead
babbit yeah baby yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
well yeah okay let's say idea town for
ranked practice this is horrible
and forge
Oh baby yeah yeah yeah Leigh van cleff
like van cleff Oh sheds a lot of blue
down
we're all calm
let's say let's say
kappa yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] I will subside
okay it's what I say William Phips I can
make sure these people aren't there okay
how does he for yourself as the mayor
[ __ ] ants changes
but shoot well with the [ __ ]
hmm let's kill this lay that clay person
here's BJ kill Jess
abaca over i like win8 of you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] they [ __ ] us
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] like I got
[ __ ] in the only way possible that's
good
do I have a will I don't think I were
admitted well did I like that
Oh interesting
Oh interesting
[Music]
buck
damn [ __ ] he's going to die sorry faith
I really got him good
Bock he's dead what God oh you [ __ ]
top board out of here all right okay
fine I guess
hey babe a
plays cassoulet thanks what God I like
how if you did it [ __ ] it's a pagoda
where she's dead is big dragon dead he's
dead too it market dot
who are sisters call yeah holy [ __ ]
town with Oh [ __ ] Russians kill
everybody
mmm
okay
everyone
so [ __ ] is that
and as website my dad
okay I guess there's upset there that's
what does have to set throw this
okay at least God [ __ ] I should be
talking somewhere you know my eyes are
[ __ ] dry put one of these bad boys
[ __ ] I [ __ ] miss my right eye
oh my god ten watts [ __ ] okay play crank
practice let's do this
I only do wearing practice okay hey baby
now let's say he'll we can [ __ ] up today
let's see you we can [ __ ] up today okay
I can't baby
okay okay I can't say just flying that
again
probably more Fargo today
mr. generic necklace go away
ho miss yo killer the [ __ ] what did the
sheriff do great Jack all right look at
the beard on this one come looks like a
little paint
to get one presentation at okay let's
say let's say Nick Crompton where do you
go why does phanpy areas okay dirty as
heck
you
I like to just say I'll be investigator
they're right down
I'll pee yeah yeah yeah
dog is dirty as heck that guy
claim
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
Jimmy quietly laughing so okay I resent
the [ __ ]
okay
Nick is gone Nick is God
back out of fact
let's go baby let's kill that [ __ ] hey
stop hey stop
a chef
hey star
what the [ __ ]
all right as heck
okay
there we go there we go oh my god I'm
back where I got them
it's kind of use it because if they like
judge you you say hey home rock out my
necks you know
no offense what the [ __ ]
kind of shame a Errani I am
see what friendly neighbor had you had
it oh [ __ ] is that man
okay Ashley Jenkins
yeah next yeah
hmm but I'll die how about I [ __ ]
ah cheers so got my brows I got my brow
you have the cure England
I asked best climber Zach love or the
river by but yeah yeah anyone here like
check out now where they land on a
hammer
Oh what does ma
we're gonna [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
that
that's some funny [ __ ] this is de Cantel
on guys I like [ __ ] they had to wrap it
matter something ours and a snapback
yeah let's sit back and let some magic
show you know Batman yeah now babe a a a
space a which just kidding okay
investigation fun I'm alone with a whip
of Fame yeah yeah I get frantic case
they just go sit on the wall fitness
Rufus with us [ __ ]
okay I don't know if I should exit this
game that's a new one kind of what the
points though and also I hope y'all I
hope y'all ain't hatin on me Anna OSB is
not the wish they said you had a set I
love chicken I love fries I love chicken
enough fries baby yeah yeah yeah nothing
L know
I chose a burn her so right [ __ ] rich
this is [ __ ] tag dealloc maybe yeah
polluted a my wife and never laughter
that's a greatness isn't Iike sorry
[Laughter]
okay okay
okay we got to get ready right now
adios PayPal
I think they lock I can tell I
what the [ __ ] is says greatness does
that and I on that night buck Calais
batch now I got some points
and it's [ __ ] hot in this house now
like that I'm going to check to make
sure there's no to turn off the stove
and answer a test
I hope that like with the game suck on
how's the game going
what the [ __ ] this game is way too long
and now I rip up anything see my next
username be Ben Affleck that's my life
where's that little - like almond nose
you know and it will [ __ ] like
hearing I guess I'll check write it Mary
that's that
I've got a report dispatch 0pi
tile-based time for you to go
I need some other game oh [ __ ]
what idea okay there we go maybe make
sure just put this up there and I will
try itself of guys hold this didn't
crash the game there we go
heavy I like that uh-huh
I'm a the fines all out there [ __ ]
whoo do we win them I think we will and
wait for ya Tom wins okay let that [ __ ]
is this good game okay um how many I
just got you all ranked I guess
[ __ ] I don't know how you [ __ ]
secret buddy what the [ __ ] is that okay
mm mm mm mm all right well I wonder
where we're going to be it dull depends
on the play style and that it depends on
the raw you know like dogs like okay
let's see what I which now I always
think it's only which to that [ __ ]
pause we share a killer janitor what the
[ __ ] is this do
yeah okay
oh wait [ __ ]
snacks
smash it okay and [ __ ] who's the other
person
Terry curves deliver laughter I'm just
doing this just to see how the wish
everything works
I can't let you later okay you're the
one that's just died [ __ ]
[ __ ] I need someone that is still alive
Santa man
okay [ __ ]
I kind of make sure as we were still
alive wait Madison [ __ ] there you go
okay let's say let's say drug cut nubs
[ __ ] our snacks in here now exit cheerio
I'm not going to [ __ ] it about if that
could be [ __ ] jester
oh [ __ ] he's got place we gesture to
be so dope I share color
swagger day we're gay
that good ol janitor starts again the
ghetto janitor strikes again
saguenay wagon ik sigh sorry slope why
was brought back the light what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] outta [ __ ] fail
oh oh [ __ ] our swaggy wagon here now
okay yes one cleaning left
and
serf that
hold off like that Boulder in here how
can I only do [ __ ] three cleanings
mmm-hmm
okay okay this is good this is good
we know we're going to go far we got to
look far Terry Fraser steps
[ __ ] I got zero clinics
hmm not bad okay let's say hello
I think we're Callum Fraser this is
pretty where this pretty weird yeah
Fraser is dad she's my freezer on here
look William Phips
all right that is the Renee with the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I got a change I don't okay I got
my fifth ucking watt
there we go
Tara crows you are a bad actor so you
will pair just get a load very gross
[ __ ] [ __ ] lived
this has got this is God I am right I
can Ollie lunch at my only defense is
living name thank you good defense to be
honest
yeah
ooh let's see if it works
good good good do you get why [ __ ] I
think it works
[ __ ]
who this with my fee of tips and I don't
work chat
oh okay
okay they're going to kill Terry next
who would their [ __ ]
ooh
[ __ ]
we ship you going at the same
what good carries mafia he's done
push him I will really [ __ ] them up
set
they're killing each other holy [ __ ]
oh my god I get a Cal Terry Crews I
don't know
shut
no one's going to count
[ __ ] we tried hard I tried hot
okay let's say out of tires let's
lighten on that one okay what the [ __ ]
can I try again [ __ ] I still got like a
[ __ ] ton I got a place tell anyone here
is in last game I can't tell legal in
here and um a screwdriver that's what I
need to know
shut Jessica Parker don't [ __ ] up
Matt Damon who I'm was missed out how to
pick my nose a little bit inna alright
when you see like outside what the
[ __ ] a lookout that's the worst roll
I saw tax
as you - you decide to watch mud sex
tonight now real marker buyer he's got
to go and it has got to go
interesting interesting
let me see what's going on a right
another dad from Obamacare appeal I see
I use this as a platform to be political
you know
[Music]
it's quite it
harry'll markiplier sucks to be you
oh sorry mark sorry
looks like let's lock up and go for jail
you know excuse the one that like mark
Jim don't watch old jail you know
mm-hmm chica the chicken Bonnie foxy
Jesus
hmm ba-bye why I love holy [ __ ] can they
attack like multiple filled once
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
buthe they're going against me they're
going against me
I can help see some butt sex tonight
Anna I decided to watch about sex
tonight
hmm
okay let's say here let's say here
ooh there we go baby there we go
okay let's say if they come body next
right
to 7-eleven fine is next Don is next I'm
taking her to the grave with me even
though she could be completely innocent
put sex Jesus I'm gonna report that
[ __ ] but sex in a poop
woooo-ooo-ooo on one raffia one mafia
they got to get rid up on okay let's get
rid of Bonnie God gets good you are a
chopper conspiracy against a town what
does in a sense
by my definitely our bye-bye and bye-bye
messed up there huh Oh God
Wow oh my god Matt to Herod strikes
again babe a
okay there's got a bit a little faster
okay debit that's gotta move a little
faster hey dot got exhale oh [ __ ] okay I
got I got a report Bonnie okay all right
yeah Bonnie
well when I would half the town halls
anyway God cam got
okay I guess we'll end up there thanks
for watching that yeah